you're spending money that you don't
have on stupid things that you don't
need because you value what other people
think of you more than what you think of
you we get an idea you think you start
thinking right you planned how do I get
to that hundred percent no you've lost
because you're gonna wake up tomorrow a
different person because you're gonna go
home today plan claim plan and wake up
tomorrow a different person and then not
take action because you're scared when I
first started my company I knew it was
gonna be hard but it didn't think it
would be this hard you never think it's
gonna be as hard as it actually is need
motivation watch the top 10 with believe
nation
I'm Evan Carmichael and here's my take
on my top 10 rule for success volume 8
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one find your one word nobody wants to
work with somebody who doesn't have
integrity but what is integrity what
does that mean for you how do you find
it how do you know what you stand for
for me it all comes down to values when
you understand what you stand for is
human being when you know what your most
important core value is then you know
how to live with integrity and you know
how to build a business based around
integrity as well and so the process
that I go through is your one word I
wrote a book about it you can read it
you can pick it up and understand how to
apply it to your business and your life
but at the core is figuring out if I had
to stand for one thing as a human being
what is that thing and so a quick
process let's go through this quick
exercise together you can pick up the
book later right now think about one who
is your favorite teacher growing up
you've had lots of teachers growing up
through high school University
Elementary School who was your favorite
teacher it wasn't because they taught
you grade 10 math it was a reason what
was it who was the person and what was
it - what was your favorite movie
growing up
pick your favorite movie and why and
then three who's your favorite
entrepreneur who's the person he looked
up to the most who did you learn the
most from who do you most want emulate
if I run through that scenario for
myself number one my favorite teachers
mad I'm far growing up at my school
Crescent school she always believed in
me she always helped me she always
guided me
she helped take me from being a B
student to A+ student in my final year
she may feel like it was possible - my
favorite movie is Seabiscuit
it's about this racehorse that's too
small and a jockey that's too big and an
owner that has no money and a trainer
that's down on his luck and they all
seem to come together to build this
racehorse that goes off and wins a whole
bunch of races and helps lift the nation
based off a true story I've seen that
movie at least thirty times three
my favorite entrepreneurs EP Giannini he
started Bank of America he was a guy who
first gave immigrants in America money
as a loan he lent money to people based
off of a handshake and a look in their
eye if you can imagine he gave Walt
Disney the money
to have his first feature-length
cartoons everybody thought he was crazy
and so what's a common thread through
all that between madam VAR Seabiscuit AP
Giannini this may all seem totally
disconnected they're not if I had to
write down three characteristics this is
what you should do you write down your
three names and then you have three
characteristics for each one the word
believe' pops off the sheet for me I
think about all of them and believe
comes at my time far believed in me my
other teachers are really nice they
really helped me it was amazing but she
really helped move the needle because
she believed in me
Seabiscuit I've seen lots of movies I
love them all it's great but the idea of
believe coming through that racehorse I
love it it's a cheesy movie but I love
it and then AP Giannini is a believe
banker let money the people on bet on
them when nobody else believed in them
my one word is belief as a result I've
built my entire business around it right
my life and my business a built around
belief my videos my newsletter my
website my speaking gigs the books that
I write everything I create it's not
just a strategy it's a way of living and
that's having integrity with yourself so
why don't I make a top ten video series
on the stupidest things that people say
because it's anti belief because it's
negative my channel would actually be
bigger if I did the negative side of
things people would rather be
entertained and laugh at others then
educate themselves and get better people
would rather sit at home and watch four
hours of Netflix every night then go off
and spend four hours learning and try to
build a business they just would we'd
rather be entertained and educated but I
don't want to be in that business I
don't want to be in a negative business
I don't want to be in the hater business
because my one word is believed and so
that's having integrity with myself and
an integrity with you guys my audience
my customers the people that I work with
and so yes integrity is at the core of
everything if you don't have integrity
people do not want to work with you but
how do you figure out what that means of
course you're not gonna go lie to
somebody right of course stealing is
gonna be bad but what else how do you
get more specific the biggest problem is
lack of clarity people don't know what
they stand for
and as a result you're living up to
other people's expectations and versions
where I want you to live inside yourself
I want you to be standing on a rock when
everybody else is sending it on
quicksand you have clarity you have
definiteness of purpose and it starts
with figuring out your one word so you
pick up the book or you can go to that
3-step process thinking about who your
favorite teacher wasn't why write three
words down for word think about what
your favorite movie is and why write few
words down for it and think about who
your favorite entrepreneur or hero is of
all time and why write three words down
from it look at what similar your one
word will pop off the page and now you
know what integrity means to you
rule number two attack judgment people
sabotage themselves because they care
too much what other people think you're
spending money that you don't have on
stupid things that you don't need
because you value what other people
think of you more than what you think of
you if you can't get out of that trap
you'll never build the lesson you want
you'll just constantly be in reaction
mode doing what other people expect of
you so I think you should attack
judgment I think it's good I think
whenever you feel that you were playing
small because of somebody else's opinion
of you then you have to go off and do
that thing you need to attack judgment I
think it's one of the greatest skills
that you can ever teach yourself one of
the greatest practices you can do on a
daily basis I think we play small by
default as humans I think it's big in to
us I think because of our survival
characteristics of how we need to fit in
to society to win I think we play small
by default and so you need to learn to
attack judgment so here's an example
my agent Steve I was on the phone with
him and I was telling him about my new
employment routine you know I can't do
much for myself right now I broke my
neck I broke my upper back I had a
concussion in the early days when I
first fell and hit my head and and I'll
look into a speak which is great for
making videos but I can't move I
couldn't put my pants on by myself I
couldn't do a lot of stuff by myself and
so my agent Steve says you need to film
your new morning routine you need to
show your audience what you're going
through you need to do an Instagram live
and show us what's happening really
I'm thinking to myself you want me to
show off me putting my pants on in the
morning I'm feeling subconscious I've
gained some weight because I haven't be
able to move around never made a video
in my underwear before you know all this
all of these thoughts going through my
head and because that's part of the
reason because I'm worried about your
judgement then I have to do it I have to
do it the next day right like ASAP you
have to go do the thing learn to attack
judgment because as long as you play
small because you're worried about
somebody else's opinions of you you'll
never go off and do the crazy things
that you want to do your entrepreneurs
you want to go off and change the world
you want to do amazing things you've got
visionary ideas of things that you want
to go off and do that means you're gonna
attack the status quo there's a lot of
people who want to protect the status
quo a lot of people so you're gonna get
judged you're gonna get attacked you're
gonna get criticized because your ideas
are different you're weird duck be proud
of it and so anytime you catch yourself
playing small worrying about somebody
else's opinion learn to attack it rule
number three take immediate action as
soon as you get that idea why you're
feeling bold while you're feeling
inspired to go off and take some kind of
action I call it the two percent
difference don't worry about trying to
get to 100% don't worry about planning
and strategizing and figuring it out and
thinking that's what most of us do we
get an idea you think you start thinking
right you plan how do I get to that
hundred percent No
you've lost because you're gonna wake up
tomorrow a different person because
you're gonna go home today plan plan
plan and wake up tomorrow a different
person and then not take action because
you're scared because your brain will
start talking you down from that crazy
big idea your brain will talk you down
from going off to living your truth
that's what's gonna happen that's what
always happens and so while you're
feeling the energy in the momentum you
got to take some action instead of
planning how to get to 100% of the way
you take action immediately on getting
2% of the way 2% the 2% difference go
from 0 to 2% if you can't take a medium
momentum to getting two percent of the
way you will never get 200% you have an
idea to make a youtube channel great go
make your video right now today ASAP the
2% difference make your first video
right now with your cell phone what most
people will do is start researching
right what am I gonna talk about
we're gonna wear what's my hair gonna
look like how what camera do I need to
get what what phone do I need to get
right what's my lighting gonna be what
microphone think think think think think
think think think think and then never
do because you're perfectionist
you're gonna perfect your way out of
ever living your truth the beginning is
messy it's supposed to be messy go off
and get your 2% difference towards
finding and living your truth quick
example my story I'm hearing Albuquerque
New Mexico right now I was walking down
a beautiful summer day last year and I
decided that I was gonna take Nina to
every city in North America with a
million-plus people every city in North
America 1 million plus people that was
my decision great what's my first step
action the two percent difference so
it's not here's what most people do it's
not go home and research how many cities
there are it's not go home and make a
plan for how we're gonna do this there's
lots of reasons why it's not gonna work
Nina's too had a full-time job I had no
idea how many cities that were I had no
idea what the next step was gonna be
just do something immediate action and
so I thought right away 5 seconds later
here's my goal great five seconds later
this weekend let's hit one City Boston
Nina never been to Boston so I thought
Boston was the closest city to Toronto
it wasn't Pittsburgh at Sheila's and on
my tour the people in Pittsburgh told me
they let me know the Pittsburgh is
closer but it doesn't matter this
weekend we're gonna go to Boston it was
a Wednesday that I decided and on Friday
night we were leaving for Boston boom I
hit 2% just 50 cities we're gonna hit
one this weekend we're gonna get 2% of
the way done on the way back from Boston
we decided to do this tour that I'm on
right now and now we're gonna hit 50% of
the cities on my list momentum that's
the thing that's missing momentum
because you're trying to be perfect
you're trying to fully understand your
truth but you can't sink your way
through your truth you have to
experience it and feel it and the
starting point is a 2% difference so
take whatever idea that you have and
train yourselves I want to burn this
into your nervous system this is one of
the most important things you can do up
all time as soon as you get an idea
action idea action idea action the more
you can shortcut that that window
instead of taking a week to take action
or daily take action immediate idea boom
some kind of 2% action and expect it not
to be perfect I expect enough to be the
playing my plane was wrong right
Pittsburgh was closer in my hand I
thought it was Boston we went down the
wrong path but the momentum is what
matters and now we're 50% of the way and
now I'm gonna close that gap and get the
rest of it the 2% difference rule number
four endure hardships in an entrepreneur
is one of the hardest things you'll ever
do in your life whether you go all-in
financially or not you're gonna go
all-in emotionally and a lot of people
they can't cut it they can't get the
cows as fast enough and so they quit
that's gonna be one of the biggest tests
for you as you get off and build your
business do you have the mental
fortitude to keep going keep driving
keep building your business in the face
of all obstacles it's the ultimate
endurance test it's the ultimate test to
see what you're made of when I first
started my company I knew it was gonna
be hard but it didn't think it would be
this hard you never think it's gonna be
as hard as it actually is I was making
$300 a month
I turned down $100,000 a year six
figures working for my dream job company
to make $300 a month and own 30% of a
company
I eat beans for lunch every day the same
bean salad for lunch mixed beans with
olive oil and herbs and garlic and salt
a little pepper because it was cheap and
it would fill me up and when I wanted to
splurge I would go to the store and get
the chunky Campbell soup clam chowder
there's a little bit more expensive but
also filming up when we went to
celebrate a win we would go to
McDonald's and get a McDonald's french
fries large fries and share between the
three of us because that's what we could
afford couldn't afford the whole meal
and even to this day the smell of
McDonald's french fries means victory
for me it's the most unhealthy thing in
the world but it still means victory for
me I made it even harder on myself and
that I isolated myself and I didn't tell
my friends that I was struggling I had
to pick one thing a month that I could
go to one friendly you know social pizza
and beer kind of thing per month because
at 20 bucks I didn't have because I'm
only making 300 a month so I isolated
myself I turned inwards I was too
embarrassed and ashamed to tell my
friends
who are off making 80 hundred thousand
dollars a year starting salary at the
University and I'm making three hundred
bucks a month I was too embarrassed and
ashamed and so I told them I'm hustling
I'm living the entrepreneur life you
know I'm grinding but really I was
struggling I had no idea what it was
doing this thing was tearing me apart
and it got to the point where I actually
quit on my business partner I told them
I quit it's easy to quit on something
and not get results when you know that
you're not putting in the effort but I
was putting in the effort every single
day showing up to my business partners
dining room table because everything
else is too small in his place to fit us
putting in the effort every single day
trying to build and grow this business
and just it wasn't working I felt
worthless as a human like why are we not
getting results when will we start the
key results and I was fed up and tired
and I told my quit like I need to find a
way to to be useful to feel valuable as
a human and so I told my quit and then I
woke up the next day and said I can't
quit because I haven't given it
everything that I've got and so there's
a two-step process that saved me that I
hope will save you if you're feeling
down and out and it's tough and you're
not getting results the first step is
use regret to fuel you I imagine my life
at 100 looking back on this moment
saying what I regret quitting it's very
rarely the things that you do that you
regret is the things that you don't do
so what I regret not continuing what I
regret not giving in my all and I try to
adopt the mantra that I would rather
know and fail to not know I would rather
know and fail than not know so I had to
see this through even if the answer was
total failure even if it never worked
that I had to see it all the way through
just to know because otherwise that
regret would eat me up and so number one
use regret when you're struggling when
it's not working out when you're not
getting results imagine yourself being
100 years old looking back and saying if
you quit now if you stop if you don't
keep going will you regret it
number
to his model success the next thing that
saved me was I asked myself that next
morning after I quit and then decided I
need to go back cuz I can't live with
regret I asked myself who has done this
before who has built the software
company up I can't be the only person
who tried to do this and I looked at
Bill Gates who started Microsoft and not
how he makes an extra million dollars
now but zero to one how did he do that
how did that happen I studied his
success I modeled the success I applied
it to my company and pretty shortly got
my first deal for thirteen and a half
thousand dollars that may not seem like
a lot of money but to me back then it
was it was hitting the lottery I'm
making 300 bucks a month now I just made
a deal for thirteen and a half thousand
that was hope that was real that was
putting my money my bank account you
know that was gonna have a full meal at
McDonald's and more important it gave me
a model that I could do again and again
and again it closed another deal and
another deal on another deal and her
business started to take off and ever
since that was 20 years ago I use the
same two-step process also if you want
to learn how to have more confidence
check out my 250 for confidence series
it's free the link to join is in the
description below if you're doing work
that you love you're more likely to
follow through you're more likely to do
it because it doesn't feel like work
because you love doing it
surround yourself with greatness if you
want to be more confident you need to
surround yourself with things that make
you feel confident find whatever the
smallest first step is and in the
smallest next that is and continue to
build those steps I mean you look back
you'll have realized that you made it's
a pretty significant progress rule
number five do the difficult things you
need to do things that make you feel
proud when things get difficult most
people will find really smart ways to
talk themselves down from doing
difficult things and the smarter you are
the better excuse slash reason you have
to not to do the thing but until you own
up and go after and chase down difficult
things you'll never be proud of yourself
and you'll never accomplish the big
goals you have for yourself so I'm here
on my tour I committed to doing 90 days
23 cities a new city basically every
four days and I broke my neck two weeks
ago I broke my neck in ten
her and I had to cancel my denver event
cuz it was in the hospital but then I
got up when I did a short version of my
Kansas City event and then I got up and
did a full version of a Minnesota event
and then I got up and did a full version
of my Milwaukee event here last night I
wanted to work that makes you feel proud
it's difficult it's hard everybody would
have understood if I cancelled right if
I said guys sorry I broke my neck broke
my back have a concussion three staples
in my head I can't keep going everybody
would have understood but I wouldn't
have felt proud and that needs to be
your asset test it's not what other
people think about you it's not when
other people let you off the hook it's
not when other people think that you're
great it's what do you think about
yourself are you proud of the decisions
that you make in your life rule number
six stop comparing yourself to others
you're constantly comparing your version
of success your version of life compared
to what you see out there other people's
versions your look at what they're doing
the Instagram when YouTube but in social
media and in the tabloids and in the you
know you look at those people you said
that's the life that I want have you no
confidence in your own version of your
life that's a problem that's what you
need to fix I often get asked on my tour
hey Evan what's the perfect morning
routine like what do you do every
morning to get yourself started what I
do almost says it matter
stop comparing yourself to me we have
different versions of what success and
balance look like I look at what the
rock does for example he needs to work
out for four hours a day he needs to do
cardio twice he needs to do weights
twice when he has to be on a movie set
by 9:00 a.m. he wakes up at 4:00 goes
and works out for four hours comes back
showers and then goes to his set and
when he's shooting a movie he'll sleep
five hours a night I think that's crazy
I don't look like the rock there's a
reason we have different priorities
different version of balance but this is
the problem because you want to work
like the rock and you want to be a good
diet like this person and you want to be
a good entrepreneur like this person a
visionary like this person and you're
constantly judging your version of your
life versus somebody else's that it's
unobtainable it's not possible
because there's no self confidence in
what you already have
it doesn't matter what I do in the
morning it doesn't matter what the rock
does in the morning what matters is you
start your day with the thing that makes
you come alive if you started your day
with the thing that made you feel bold
and self-confident every single day your
life would look dramatically different
one year from today than where you are
right now it just would but what that
thing is is different for everybody we
have different goals we have different
things that drive and move us and so it
starts with having the self-awareness to
figure out what it is that you want and
then the self-confidence to believe in
it enough that when you see something
shiny over here you're not swayed by
right and think that you suck because
this person's crushing it in a different
field rule number seven bring value I
think most people are confused about
money most people don't have a healthy
relationship with money there are the
people who think that money is
everything the money is the only
important thing in the world then you
need to chase it down and is your duty
and responsibility and obligations like
it's number one the person walking into
my house and my place of business that's
my next suit that's my next payment
that's my next whatever it's only
focused on money and there's other
people who think money is the root of
all evil
and that money is a bad thing money is a
tool money helps you get a lot of things
done
money helps you go places money helps
you accomplish your mission money needs
to be in your top five it's just not
number one money needs to be in your top
five if money does not become important
at some point to you if it's not in your
top five priorities you'll never make
money and you'll always be by yourself
struggling trying to figure out how to
make something work but it's not number
one either if you put money above all
else you'll end up doing a lot of work
that you hate and you never get good at
it just because you're chasing
opportunities this is a big reason why
so many entrepreneurs fail you're just
chasing the hottest thing for this year
that you don't have a passion or
interest in and then you lose because
the people who love that destroy you
when I first started doing this helping
entrepreneurs I never thought I was
gonna make money my first speaking gig
my first option to help people was in
Canada in my hometown of Toronto was at
a YMCA it was a free event they had an
entre nursery program they asked me to
come and speak to their members it was
free I wasn't getting paid to do it just
wanted to help out I just sold my
business
wanted to give back I was saying yes to
everything that she didn't even know
what I want to do next and so I show up
and this is big room full of chairs and
only three people show up to that first
event only three people and as soon as I
walked in the room I saw three people my
heart sank I felt like I'm never gonna
be able to make anything from this if
only three people show up to a free
event how am I ever gonna make money
from it I didn't know but I keep my best
to those three people I know that I
helped those three people and had an
impact on their lives we then went for
coffee afterwards and continued the
conversation I know that I helped them
and it filled my soul and had to find a
way to keep doing it I knew I had to
find a way to keep doing it even if I
never made money and so I did I kept
doing speaking gigs I did my website I
did my youtube channel and slowly slowly
slowly slowly it started to come in as I
figure it out
the second key important piece which is
figuring out how to bring value to other
people when you find something that you
love doing and you combine it with how
it brings value to other people that's
when you start making money it was
something that you just love doing but
nobody else likes it there's zero value
to anybody else you have a hobby you
have a hobby if you're only chasing
stuff that people like in need but you
don't like doing it you're never gonna
get great at it you might make a little
bit of money but you're never gonna get
great at it you're never gonna be
all-time
you're never gonna build a huge business
and so it's that combination of doing
work that you love doing and mix it with
where does an opportunity that people
need it's a problem that you are solving
it makes those things together you have
a super successful business rule number
eight start small entrepreneurs don't
have to be giant risk takers some
entrepreneurs have to go all-in it's the
only way they can operate earn the boats
have no plan B have no escape no
parachute all in one way trip it's the
only way they operate but there's tons
of successful entrepreneurs who win by
building sustained momentum by taking
small successful risks over
and over again but never put it all on
the line I love small starts i love
finally ways to get started on tons of
different ideas and seeing what sticks
and where my heart lies and following
those through but i'll never put in tons
of money before putting in the effort
and energy to see if i'd love it
to try to get results so I look at
YouTube as an example it's ten years of
having this channel it's wow that's
crazy
I started it just as an experiment I had
a successful website I had eight people
on my team building up this new web
business that I was a part of and I just
wanted to try YouTube I wanted to make
visual content I love learning from
successful people and so I wanted to
tell those stories in the visual way
that plus people kept asking me
questions I'd sold my company and so
they asked me questions Evan how do I do
this how do I do that great so I would
make videos answering questions for
people but I did it all myself right
like I got some friends to volunteer to
help me make some of my early videos and
then everything was me I had money I
sold my business I had a team working on
my website but I was doing this little
skunkworks project all by myself just to
go just make it happen just to see just
to see if I'd like it see if I can build
some momentum and so I researched and I
edited and I filmed I did everything and
as it started then to make some money
then I could invest that money back into
my business and then it slowly built up
to the point where we're at right now
rule number nine be the chief goal
officer you need to be people's chief
goal officer if you want to move them
into action if you want them to win you
have to speak to them in their language
and the things that they care about the
worst advice you could give somebody is
what you would do if you treat everybody
who works with you and for you like the
way you would be treated you're gonna
lose forever you're never gonna build
the organization you want because people
have different goals and it's your job
to understand what they are so I'm doing
this tour right now 90 days 23 cities I
often get asked by people
hey Evan what book should I read what
video do you recommend from your channel
for an entrepreneur time six thousand
videos the worst advice I could give is
to give a generic answer the worst
advice I could give is to one
I would watch like here's a video that I
loved the most for me to give a good
answer to you I need to know your
problem I need to be your chief goal
officer I need to understand what you're
struggling with I can give you the
greatest book recommendation of all time
but if it's not the thing that you care
about right now it's not going to serve
you and so before you give advice before
you try to help somebody else out be
their chief goal officer there's two
ways to do it understand or who and
understand their why their who is their
most important one word core value and
they're why is their purpose and their
purpose comes from their pain so look at
their who I'll use an example with Alex
who who runs trying to dance salsa for
me his who is belong his one word is
belong he wants to create a place where
people feel like they belong it's the
one word for him it's a one word for TBS
I know that's what he really cares about
for me belonging doesn't really matter
if I don't feel like I belong in a room
I'm not bothered by it I don't care what
other people think of me it's it's so
lowdown on my list of priorities and
values of what I personally care about
but for him it's number one he wants to
make people feel like they belong that's
his one word most important core value
that's his who so I understand a little
bit more about him I understand how to
push him the next is your why your
purpose comes from your pain for him he
struggled so much in in making friends
and feel accepted he had super sweaty
hands and when he held the girl's hand
he would slide out because he sweat so
much and it tied into him never feel
like he belong and so this is now his
purpose for life is to help other people
feel like they belong that there's a
space for them to come to and feel like
they belong his favorite movie of all
time is Hercules the Disney movie the
cartoon were in that song he says
something about a place where you belong
and when he hears that song he cries
great this is Alex right I might play
that song for myself and think that's a
good song I'm gonna play that song for
somebody else and they hate that song
screw Hercules amazing everybody's
different you need to be their chief
goal officer so if I'm talking out to
trying to motivate and push him and have
him build an amazing company that he's
proud of I'm gonna use words like belong
I'm gonna use movie references like
Hercules I'm gonna talk
Creed in the place where people can come
together and feel like they're finally
accepted because that's at the core what
he's all about that's me being his chief
goal officer and so you need to do that
for everybody on your team you need to
do that for every customer that you work
with stop treating everybody the same
way there's the classic rule of do unto
others as you would have them do unto
you and that's great and that's treating
people with compassion and care and
kindness but everybody's motivated by
different things and if you can only
treat people one way the way that you
would like to be treated
you're gonna only have success with a
very narrow band of people a very narrow
band of customers a very narrow band of
employees a very narrow band of partners
you're gonna stay in this tiny little
lane your entire life and never build a
huge company but if you can learn to be
somebody's chief goal officer if you can
learn to understand what drives that
moves them pushes in what they're who is
what they're why is why they're here
what they're trying to accomplish you
start building an eight-lane
superhighway and you can build a company
that can take over the world and rule
number 10 the last one before a very
special bonus clip is enjoy the process
I'm much more won enjoy the process of
the work that I'm doing then then
getting the end result when I've made my
youtube channel and we hit a million
subscribers
everybody's asked me what's the
celebration what are you guys gonna do
what's the plan no I didn't need to
celebrate we ended up doing a livestream
because I wanted to celebrate with you
guys because it was important for you
but for me I don't I don't care to
celebrate like let's keep going I love
this is the celebration making these
videos is the celebration not getting
the plaque not crossing the million aqua
XYZ only results matter of course
but the process enjoying the process and
doing difficult things is how I get
myself to take action not visualizing
the end result now I've got a special
bonus tip on how to stop saying someday
that I think you're gonna enjoy but
before that is over the three-point
landing questions let's go from just
watching the video to taking action here
we go question number one what is your
one word number two how will you start
to attack judgment and number three what
will you take in
action on today you're saying someday
because you're scared you're scared of
failing you're scared of losing money
and you're scared of what people will
say about you if you don't win but being
scared isn't a good enough reason if
you're consistently making decisions
from a place of fear you'll never do
anything great because all great things
in life come on the other side of fear
so I'm here on this tour right now
filming to my last stop here in
Cleveland and starting this tour was 90
days 23 cities I was afraid to do it
because my agent told me I needed to
charge for the event I had a hard time
charging entrepreneurs because it's
where I came from because I didn't have
a lot of money I wouldn't have been able
to afford the $45 ticket to come see
someone like this if that person came to
Toronto and so I was afraid combine that
with my biggest fear being letting
people down my biggest fear in the world
is that I'm gonna disappoint people that
people would show up and pay to see me
and I would let them down and they'd go
home feeling like it was a waste of
their money and so you combined those
things now it's not just one event that
I get to be afraid for it's every four
days for 90 days right 23 different
stops getting up and facing my fear
every single time and because I caught
that fear than I had to do it here's
what happens smart people we come up
with really smart ways as to why we
shouldn't do something right you will
come up with really smart ways why you
should not do something but deep down
you're really just afraid meanwhile
dummies are off winning off of your idea
people who aren't as smart people who
don't have as much intention a positive
goodwill people who don't have as big a
mission as you do people who don't want
to serve as much as you do they're off
there they're winning off of your idea
because they just started meanwhile
you're trying to figure out and Tinker
and plain but really you're just afraid
to execute
if you want more me check out my top 50
rules video the link is right there next
to me I think you'll enjoy it continue
to believe and I'll see you there if you
have to get motivated every single day
then you are in the wrong business the
people who win work the hardest because
they love what they do